the skill set of content in Social
matters a lot more than if you're a
travel blogger there's a million travel
bloggers that don't get any views
attention is the number one asset I
wanted to ask you for a lot of Americans
they're moving overseas and they are
becoming digital Nomads so I wanted to
know if you didn't want to become
necessarily A travel vlogger what's a
good platform to use and what's a good
strategy if you're an entrepreneur and
business owner but don't necessarily
want you know do traveling so you so
you're saying you don't want to travel
no I'm going to travel but I don't want
to document it like that I want to
educate people but I'll be in different
locations so would they be more
interested in the different locations or
are they interested in what I'm teaching
well well a bigger question is what
would you like to teach like what are
you trying to accomplish right because I
love that you're thinking about them
which is exactly right but ironically
the best way in the world to be selfless
is to be selfish
meaning for me for example why I'm even
on this stage right now and why you know
me is I think the world lacks
perspective on how much good there is
and how much opportunity there is and
how much is going well we are fixated on
what's not going well so I have a
passion to talk about those things and I
had a passion to talk about
entrepreneurship and wine and lots of
stuff many of things that weren't really
popular when I first started talking
about about them and so I can give you a
lot about what the audience is going to
want but first I want to make sure I
understand what you want what would you
want to do what with the content what
are you trying to accomplish I would
love to educate them in dope
environments that's what I would like to
do educate them on the things that I've
been learning throughout the years
firearms training or personal defense
and how they can protect themselves
wherever they go around the world but
making sure I do that in a peaceful
place for me and my mental health I love
that so the key here is it doesn't
matter where you are to do that I built
one of the largest wine shows in the
world from New
[Music]
Jersey and when I did it in
2006 like everybody was like well you
got to do this in Napa you have to move
to Napa and I'm like why so you know are
are people intrigued by the
visualization of where people are yes
but it sounds like you're trying to
teach people something that's important
to many people and the setting or the
backdrop is not very very very important
to that it's a component but you can do
that anywhere and anywhere and I think
the question becomes do you actually
know how to do it ironically this a fake
cover but I announced this today so I'm
launching this next year right and it's
heavy detail on what I'm going to tell
you right now which is it doesn't matter
if you're in Sri Lanka Japan or
Manhattan if you want to reach people
you need to make sure you know what time
to post with the first three seconds of
the video look like what the thumbnail
looks like how LinkedIn Works different
than YouTube you have to understand the
distribution and the content that works
in it and then more importantly the
slang the the wording the copywriting
the skill set of content and social
matters a lot more than if you're a
travel blogger there's a million travel
bloggers that don't get any views 10
million travel bloggers that don't get
any views how well do you know your
content of all the things you've learned
self-defense all this firearm trading
and then how good are you at the craft
of putting out the videos the pictures
and the written words on these 10 social
media platforms that dictate Society oh
that's great um next question Gary
grateful to have a little time with you
I'm Chris I'm known as the yoga boss and
my intention is to inspire and Empower
people with yoga meditation and I've
used nfts to help give people access to
meditation and I feel like especially in
the last year the criticism of and
skepticism around nfts has created a
huge marketing challenge so I'm curious
how your vision of how creators can
utilize nfts as vehicles for Consumer
engagement and customer retention has
evolved over the last year just patience
you're absolutely right no different
than in
2001 when all the internet stocks
crashed and everybody had a bad taste
about the internet and all the Articles
were written that the internet was a fad
all I was doing at wine library.com was
just building I was just building the
website better I was getting my email
newsletter better I was making the store
better same with be friends as the nft
thing had a over excitement and then Rec
correction crash I've been working on
the physical stuff squish mows trading
cards pins and refining our web 3
products and services building and
preparing for the next wave and so to
your point you know I'm not in the
business of convincing I'm in the
business of conviction
so my conviction for the blockchain and
for web 3 and for where nfts are going
to be in society hasn't changed in the
height nft land and it sounds like this
might have hit your radar I was making
videos that 99% of mfts were goingon to
go to zero because nfts are a platform
not individual projects so you're right
right now the overall consensus on nfts
because people are headline readers is
the same way people treat everything
don't fully know and they're just kind
of like looking at it and there was over
speculation 99% of sports cards are not
worth money Michael Jordan's rookie card
is 99% of Contemporary Art is not worth
money but Rasheed Johnson's art is 99%
of sneakers that people wear are not
collectible Sneakers but there's sneaker
conon and there's all sorts of Jordans
in Air Force ones that are rare and sell
so people got caught up last year two
years ago thinking everything that was
an nft was worth money no it's a digital
collecti or in your world it's a digital
asset or marketing tool to get people to
make it a utility a membership there's a
lot of things that are going to be used
for in the meantime to your point you
can't lead with nfts right now because
it's not that time you need to be
building your skill set and be prepared
for when it is that time again whether
that's six months a year or two years
from now ironically nfts from a
collectible and trading standpoint have
had their best week this week in the
last 18 months or 12 months so you know
you never know when going to happen but
I think for you right now I'd focus more
on content and social networks while
being behind the scenes educating
yourself on all the advancements of
ethereum and new nft protocols and keep
practicing and then be ready to hit hard
when it's back just like 2005 six7
internet was that post 2001 hey gu I
want to jump in really quick I want to
just ask a question how do you stay
oppressed because you know you're always
right on the on the edge of of culture
where things are going and then you you
know start leading it how do you and
what's your strategy when you learn
something you just jump in but what do
you how do you keep a breast of it and
then how do you make those decisions and
say I'm going to do it's a great
question um I put in the work like I'm
Gonna Fly I got Vegas F1 right a lot of
Business Development this weekend coming
up I have a five hour flight at 8:30 in
the morning on Friday from from 8:30 to
11:30 on that 5 hour flight I'll get my
work done my email this that the last
two hours I'll do all sorts of random
curious stuff that's happening in the
world for example if you can see I'm
wearing a corduroy hat right uh as you
know because you're hip you know uh
people are rocking corduroy hats I'm
actually curious
why like just like in the late 90s early
2000s corduroy hit pants right now
corduroy hats cordoy jackets they're
hitting again I like to know why why
like and then I'll go into chat GPT or
Google or social media and actually
spend an hour trying to figure out who
popped it off did Michael B Jordan rock
it at Paris fashion week and that got it
going is there some Tik tocker nobody's
ever heard of but she's the next
fashionista was it pushed by a brand
that really wanted it to pop off and
they had the juice at the moment to get
it done I always want to know why things
are happening what Netflix show is
working what food trend is happening
what part of the world ispp off like why
why why why why everything is curiosity
everything is why but here's the thing
about even at my state of where I am in
my career where my time is now really
valuable I still think that I outc
curious most
people you know and so for me I saw ice
spice happening six months before people
really felt it because I'm in the
trenches I'm looking at Social I'm
looking at Google Trends I'm just
listening you know it's funny I'm such a
talker you know this actually you and I
had night in can talking about a pretty
important subject you know around race
and life and you got to see a version of
me that most people don't get to see we
sat on a boat you and I for three four
hours yeah and I only talked once
yeah yeah and it was not only because I
was being respectful to the subject
matter it's because I listen way more
than I talk y'all see me when I talk 90%
of my day is behind the scenes MH and so
I think the reason I've always been on
it is I'm not sure how many people are
outworking me in paying attention to
culture culture the way now we now talk
about it which is like let's call it
what it is black urban culture which is
the cool but then you know Midwest
culture hunting and fishing country
music Latin trap food Trends diet Trends
why is stoicism increasing why are
people walking barefoot and grass for
ground ing psychedelics Japan anime
video games fortnite recall like I'm in
it you know I I and I and I think that's
one of the reasons why you know I don't
know if you you saw when when when I was
on the boat I I had a Manga comic I had
created and the artist that actually
created and and similarly I think that
curiosity is one of the strongest tools
that don't like I read Japan I read
Chinese and Korean fiction every night
and I've been reading it for a while now
curiosity is probably going to be the
thing that allows us to really solve
some of the wicked problems just by
just 100% And and it's my entertainment
when people watch Netflix or you know
obviously I love my sports teams so they
get precedent when they're playing but
for me it's like fun you know think
about all the people that love curling
up to a book for two hours before they
go to bed or watching the same movie or
watching a Netflix show or drinking wine
or going out at night clubbing like it
is my great joy to sit for two three
hours of curious culture digging a night
and I just think I'm outworking the
world on that and I also think I'm
naturally talented at making the next
leap which is some people could read and
see a lot of Trends around cupcakes but
I have a knack for understanding what
does that mean and what's going to
happen next MH hey my name is Charles
Manfield and um you've had your company
uh well one of your companies your media
company since 09 yes sir I wonder what
would you do if you were starting that
from scratch today how would you
approach it if you were building your
media company uh right now yes sir I
would do the same exact thing I did in
09 first I would keep cost down I
started the company in a conference room
of another company so I had no cost
because I didn't have money I believe
when you start a company
you need to start from the dirt when
come you know everyone talks about I
need to raise capital I need to raise
capital I always get scared because I
think like you know like you know when
we were kids if you were the kind of kid
that got like five bucks and then you
bought some [__] in the store real quick
and your grandma would be like man that
money's burning a hole in your pocket
you know those people I feel like that's
what a lot of Founders do when they
raise Capital they spend it on dumb [__]
so the first thing I would do is keep it
humble and the second thing I would do
is what I did with this Med company
which is sell things you know what I
knew in 2009 was social media in a world
that most people didn't know if you're
asking this question for yourself you
got to ask yourself what do you know
people start companies around where they
think money is versus starting companies
around things they like or things they
know the only companies that I get
excited about as an investor is if I
feel the founder really knows it or
really loves it and you show me somebody
who really knows it and loves it and
I'll show you something I'm really
interested in so I think that keep it
humble and keep it slow people want it
fast and then do something that you
really know or you really love I really
think that framework puts you in the
best position to have a successful
company and then be patient because it
takes time hi Gary my name is Jose
Marquez uh I'm the the chairman and CEO
of of tech Latino uh you've heard of
uson Ivan Peña has been uh one of our
members that has been in who lives in
New York and ran our chapter for a while
he's a good friend of yours and I wanted
to say hello first of all thank you
brother second of all I want to say
thank you for introducing me to yard
sales because let me tell you I've
become a yard sales Warrior and because
of your advice um I found a very very
prosperous uh card of Roberto Clemente's
wiie
card unbelievable you know and that was
right there and in the box and people
didn't even they didn't even know it was
there I thank you for that because that
was a
$21,000 winfall that I made for two
grand for two thou $2 I'm
sorry2 21,000 for $2 investment I know
brother it's there I keep try listen I I
make those garage sale yard sale videos
because so many people email me and say
Gary you're talking about investing in
Facebook I got
$48 and I was like you know what I'm
going to start making content for people
who have $48
because and I know exactly what I did
and I know what's going on out there I
believe that most Americans are lucky
enough to be in a place where they could
go garage saleing or thrift store
shopping or Goodwill store shopping and
spend $30 and make $300 $400 every week
and that really matters for a lot of
people a lot of famili and obviously
you're talking about a very incredible
find but for a lot of people the emails
I get like somebody emailed me actually
yesterday I think they're going to
Disney World they're paycheck to
paycheck family but the entire family
for Christmas is going to Disney World
proper too like nice hotel good flight
and all of the money happened in the
last five months making
$7,000 buying $1 items on at garage
sales and selling them for 30 40 bucks
on eBay
Facebook Marketplace it's there for
people that want to go get it and it's
fun if you like it so here's my business
question I've been doing Tech Latino now
for 27 years wow we have brought the
Hispanic Community from point A to point
from nothing but not even knowing what
Cisco was to over ending on cell
phones and getting that uh Broadband
experience that they needed and they
couldn't what do we do next as an
organization to help our community I
mean look I think there's a lot of ways
to think about that I think similar to
the first question it's what do you feel
that is most needed I
believe education is massive and then
the next part is the putting people on
so for example maybe we can do a
business development deal where people
that want to either enter marketing and
technology or switch careers and get
into it I'm a unique entrepreneur where
if someone is in join Tech Latino and
they you know they're a lawyer but they
don't want to be they want to be in like
digital marketing I'm not the kind of
guy who's scared to hire someone like
that just because it's not on their
resume so I think what's next is going
from education to becoming a place that
puts people on and start business
developing with things that creates
opportunity so I'm Isabelle Moi and one
of the hats I wear is as a professor at
Georgia State University and this is
where we're calling you
from coming right I you've been very
transparent about how you feel about how
Ed in very colorful language so
challenge you and I love that and so but
assume for a moment that we are working
with a population that is in college and
committed to continuing so they've
already made that decision at our best
we a community of practice with a
captive audience that's willing to learn
so how do we leverage that time at the
highed experience in our resources to
help them develop their entrepreneurial
skills which is literally something that
transcends discipline and that will be
perhaps more useful long term than the
actual craft that they using in in a
moment I love it couple things one on
the subject matter of higher ed I
actually am dramatically more as you can
imagine when when in context are clipped
in a certain way it seems that there's a
certain point of view I have on higher
ed but just so because I respect it so
much I want you to hear this you know
obviously I'm 40 I actually turned 48
today is my birthday when I grew up
every single kid kid in junior high in
high school was told that if you do not
go to college you are a Monumental
failure in society so a lot of the
content I started creating 20 years ago
was like look college is not for
everyone I'm one of those people but boy
do I think college and higher ed and
advanced even you know the highest
levels of Ed is exactly right for a lot
of people I genuinely believe that my
big passion is trying to make sure that
people are self-aware to your point what
I love about your question is look I
believe where highered struggles for
people that are looking to be an
entrepreneurship is similar to the
concept of reading about how to exercise
versus exercising and so what do I think
you can do in this captive audience we
have to go to the field and do
entrepreneur classes from your
incredible institution to Babson to USC
to all these places I've come and spoke
they must require these kids or people
that are transitioning into new chapters
in their life they must requ require
them to do it's very very hard to get
good at swimming without swimming it's
very hard to get good at cooking by
watching unlimited content about cooking
and reading cooking books must cook and
if we're going to advance their
entrepreneurship yall need to create
programs where the entire semester is
actually being an
entrepreneur love it uh one more Gary hi
Gary happy birthday thanks for being
here Catherine Johnson I'm an executive
with storage distributed cloud storage
and Sher of storage Institute um my
question for you is what um excites you
most about the future of technology and
what scares you most about it great
question um what scares me is that
people are scared of
it we're we're incredibly good at
demonizing technology what excites me is
it's the undefeated advancement of the
human race everything we are today is
based on people innovating in
technology 80% of us were on farms 150
years ago until we started inventing the
tractor so what I what I'm excited about
is it's why the world continues to get
better we we we sit and listen there are
unlimited problems humans are flawed but
but we continue to get better and better
and better even though it doesn't feel
like that in Social and traditional
media so technology is why are life EX
and all these things there's so much
good about technology what I fear about
it is we're going to over demonize it
because it's getting more powerful and
what I mean by that is of course I
understand what AI means it means it may
commoditize something that is special my
entire life is based on my brain power
if I if everyone takes every video of me
and everything I've ever put on the
internet and put it into an AI learning
bot my special sauce gets commoditized
I'm not confused I also know that I can
adjust
I believe in the human spirit and so I'm
concerned that we continue to demonize
technology to a point where we start to
suppress it and manipulate it into
something that doesn't have the
potential to bring as much value
ironically it's similar to the last
question my issue with education is the
way that we package and sell it not the
concept of Education there's nothing I
believe in more than education my most
emotional exciting answer in this entire
interview was me staying up at night
educating and trying to be educated so
you know I think I think our
relationship with technology is you know
this we all know this 15 years ago all
the tech stuff was clapped for and
amazing and doing these positive things
now it feels like it's all bad AI is
gonna ruin the world I'm not naive but
boy am I practically optimistic and so I
you know when when when parents are like
these kids they're on their phone and
they're constantly under phone I look at
them and say so be a
parent right like succumbing to like we
like like what H like all of us in this
call like we were parented if my mom
didn't want me watching TV I wasn't
watching TV we need to focus on Modern
parenting issues not on technology
issues I know that's
[Music]
right
h